[Music]
I've been Frankel product manager on the
Google Play instant team and I focus on
games today we have Jam City King and
Zynga with us to talk about Google Play
instant but before we get started I'm
gonna provide you some context for the
panel discussion so last year at i/o we
launched instant apps and since then
we've been pretty busy we've enabled in
synapse on over 1 billion devices and
we've made major improvements to our
tooling and Android studio and most
recently at the game developer
conference in March we announced that
instant apps was finally coming to games
and this week we were excited to
announce that Google Play Instant is now
available to all game developers now
let's take a look at Google Play instant
in action
[Music]
[Applause]
you're above
[Music]
[Applause]
so King's candy crush team just launched
that app this past Tuesday and you can
check it out on the Play Store today so
just think about that for a second
that's candy crush one of the most if
not the most successful mobile games
ever coming to Google Play instant and
what gets partners like King excited is
the vision that bringing instant to
games can transform game discovery and
we know that this is possible because we
have seen this movie before
whenever media becomes instant
consumption goes up speed is a huge
competitive advantage we've seen this
with streaming music and movies and
before that Google proved the
transformative impact of speed with
Instant Search and we want to do the
same thing for games because we believe
that instant will do the same thing for
you the game developer imagine users
trying more games exploring more genres
and ultimately finding more games they
love to play that would have a
transformative impact on your business
and over the course of our early access
program the data has proven this theory
out today the most visible entry point
to an instant app is a try Now button as
you can see here and with just the try
Now button partners are already seeing
at up to 20% increase in user
acquisitions again that impact is from
try now alone which just scratches the
surface of the overall Google Play
instant opportunity people will also be
able to discover your games through ads
through the play games app through
social invites and banners and
collections on the Play Store and today
we're announcing that in synapse is
coming soon to pre-registration soon
players that pre-register can also get a
sneak preview
of your game and when you promote
pre-registration through social media
email or your website users can
instantly play that game from any
Android device it's an awesome way to
introduce your game to the world and as
you look at what our partners have done
with the discovery services that I just
described and you hear about what
they're excited about doing in the
future you'll start to see how important
a role Google Play Instant can play
throughout the lifecycle of a game from
the pre-launch phase when your goal is
to make your launch as big as possible
you know to build the hype machine
around your game and once you've had
that big launch and you've acquired a
bunch of users you want your game to go
viral you want your players to invite
their friends to the party so to speak
and after your game has been around for
a while your goals end up changing your
focus then turns to retaining your
existing players and bringing back those
that may have churned at each stage the
right instant experience can play an
integral role in your game success and
there are three types of instant
experiences among the many many that we
saw among our partners it was very
difficult to choose just these three but
I wanted to highlight these three today
for you the first is the mini game a
mini game is often a gaming experience
that is complementary to the full game
and is a great fit for pre-registration
dance VLEs mini game here it lets you
choreograph a routine by manipulating
the individual limbs on this awesome
looking character here and once you are
done you can share an animated gif with
all of your friends it offers endless
combinations of moves and plenty of
entertainment to occupy players all the
way through to the eventual launch of
the game the second is what I'm calling
the core gameplay preview and the goal
of this archetype is to provide a
glimpse
of what players will experience after
the tutorial in introductory levels this
is a great game and a great type for
different experiences that have a deep
upgrade system for example such as
zombie gunship revenant like you can see
here in this example the installed app
at the top typically starts you off with
just a single weapon it's not unusual to
let people slowly acclimate to new game
mechanics and so forth so you start off
with a single machine gun and the zombie
horde that's arriving up there is
arriving at a relatively modest pace
contrast this with the instant
experience which you can see down here
on the left in this one
you don't just get one machine gun but
you get two machine guns you get a
high-power sniper rifle and Hellfire
missiles the whole experience is
attended to get your adrenaline pumping
and it's a great fit for try now for ads
and other user acquisition channels and
if you're focused on bringing back
churned users the game highlights
pattern might be the right fit for you
the candy crush experience is a great
example of this to build their instant
app the candy crush team selected five
levels from the more than 3,000
available in the full game starting with
level 16 going all the way up to level
590 and each was selected to highlight a
unique combination of game mechanics I
really like playing level 590 which you
can see here there's a conveyor belt
that perpetually moves candies around
and there is this really fascinating
portal right in the middle of it which
you can't see right now you can baby see
there now and through which candies
magically disappear the goal of this
type of experience is to provide a
glimpse of what you'd be what you've
been missing out on since the last time
you played and it's very effective so
now that you have a sense of the role
Google Play Instant can play throughout
the lifecycle of a game
turn our attention to how you build
these types of experiences and just like
we want to make it as easy as possible
for users to start playing your games we
also want to make it easier for you the
game developer to build these
experiences and we've made a substantial
investment in this area first we've
adapted the instant app framework to
better suit the unique needs of game
developers there are three changes that
we made to the framework we raised the
size limit to 10 megabytes we enabled
the progressive download of assets and
executable code and very importantly we
integrated with game engines and added
support for native code and OpenGL and
that last point is vitally important
because it means you can use the same
code base as your full game to build
your instant app and by integrating with
game engines like unity we've made it
possible to build with the tools that
you're already familiar with to make
this possible for unity developers
possibly many of you in the audience
here today we have to work closely with
the world's most widely used game engine
you today through this close
collaboration millions of unity
developers will be able to optimize
their current and future games for
Google Play instead and to that end
we've built the Google Play instant
unity plugin the plugin simplifies
building and deploying an instan app all
from within the unity IDE and it will be
available in the coming weeks and if
you're a uni developer and you want to
start building an instant experience
today you recommend you join our unity
beta program and you can sign up at this
link here in the lower left hand corner
and I'll review this at the end too so
you don't have to immediately break out
your photos and take a picture and if
you sign up today you'll get the latest
news and access to beta features we're
also excited to announce that Koko's has
added instant support to their IDE Cocos
creator and have gone beyond supporting
Google Play Instant as a bill target by
adding tools that simplify the process
of building an instant app
Koko's is added two steps to their
standard bill process just for this
purpose record and refactor steps on the
recording step you play your game in the
cocoa simulator which tracks which
assets are used and when and then in the
refactor step you use a visual nonlinear
editing style tool to define the
boundaries of your instant experience
and assets are broken down by category
as you can see here to support further
optimizations
Koko's has made an alpha build available
for the adventurous to try and you can
check it out today with that now that
I've set the context let's bring our
esteem panel up on the stage to talk
about their vision for and experience
with in synapse folks come up
thank you so why don't we kick things
off with each of you introducing
yourselves talking a bit about your
background and any other thoughts you
think might be interesting for the crowd
hello everyone I'm Marcela Fredo I'm the
director of engineering at sham city and
we were in charge of creating the Google
Play instant experience for Panda pop
game hi I'm Olivia you vice-president of
platform partnerships at King and we
created two Google Play instant
experiences one with bubble witch 3 and
then just recently earlier this week on
Tuesday with candy crush saga who am i
name is Kyle Rushton I'm a senior
director of product management at Zynga
work been for the last six years and I
work at Zynga and our central product
management team I worked in both the
Zynga solitaire and words with friends
to Google Play instant experiences
awesome thank you for that so first
question how do you see instant an
instant experiences impacting the
overall gaming landscape so the moma
gaming landscape it's more competitive
than ever at this moment and we see a
Google instant replay instant as a very
valuable tool to for developers to
acquire new users into their games so I
think that that's a great word in your
friend
so at King I think we think it can you
know completely change the way that
games are discovered so there's a ton of
different untapped opportunities that
we're looking into whether its
advertising cross promotion and our game
social so there's a bunch of different
opportunities that we have any we looked
at for Google Play instant so there's a
lot of untapped potential yes so I think
in the short term when thinking about
App Store discovery will ultimately see
more consumers trying games which will
ultimately lead to more installs and
longer and better engagement but
thinking longer term I think it allowed
developers to sort of reshape the way
they think about discovery in the first
place and
think outside the box about how we bring
our experiences to consumers in ways
they're outside of traditional app store
awesome so a couple other questions here
for you guys what instant use cases have
you tried and what use cases are you
most excited about
so for us we built the first 10 levels
of the game for for users to play and
then they are able to carry over their
progress into the full app when they
install it so it's more like the core
gameplay right that you made and in the
future we see that we are going to
explore probably sharing the game with
your other with your friends that's
right so this would be like a social
invite use case yes yes no Facebook it's
okay yeah so I think I mentioned earlier
I think we're pretty excited about all
the different use cases probably
specifically on the performance
marketing side once it's available and
then also for our you know for our side
also cross promotion it's really
important as you brought up earlier we
have a ton of laps players on candy
crush saga so it's a great way for us to
bring players back for them to see all
the you know everything that's happened
with the game all the new features and
for people to remember you know about
the game again so I think those are sort
of the main use cases were pretty
excited about and social as well as
Marcelo mentioned seems to be a common
theme yes yeah so today we've been
focused primarily or almost exclusively
on try now so in trying to optimize
conversion funnel through App Store I
think what I'm most excited about
perhaps this is you know he's already
said social a few times a little bit
part of my Zynga DNA as well it's
absolutely sort of exposure invites and
social sharing I think on native you
know driving morality and social growth
has always been challenging so in the
recipient side of that experience
there's always a lot of friction for
user receiving an invite to think about
what they foresee
you go to the App Store download the app
install the app and then ultimately you
know potentially playthrough if a to E
and then find out what their friend was
actually trying to share with them on a
world of instant where you can just
share that experience perhaps you know
play a move and words with friends share
it with your friend and they immediately
open the game board was really
transformative in the way we would think
about discovery and sharing it up in the
first place so common theme here social
good and there's lots of other
opportunities as well I'd love to hear
your thoughts on but all the things that
you've implemented so far what's been
the impact you've seen and what do you
anticipate in the future from the next
project that you do with Google Play
instant well I think social will be
really important in the in that sense
being able to just click and being able
to play the game that's going to be
really important it removes the friction
of the installation which is where
people actually are eager to play the
game and they probably need to wait 10
15 20 seconds to download it and being
able to take advantage of that eagerness
and I think that's going to be really
important thank you so from our side we
actually see a lot of users like a high
intent to install and then we've
actually seen a lot of users who played
the instant game actually go to install
Bob which three are candy crush saga so
that's what we're really excited about
and then I think if there's different
ways to continue to optimize the funnel
from you know instant to actually
installing the game yeah so we've been
really encouraged by the level of
engagement we've seen with the try now
experience and the demand were seeing
from the consumer side appeal really
being interested just check something
out and not necessarily download the
full experience but our focus has been
purely on driving installs and
conversion they looking forward in
addition to sort of moving forth that
experience we also look to drive things
like reengagement and
reactivations in other sort of core
metrics a part of the experience beyond
just optimization of the insulation
funnel that makes a lot of sense so you
know we've heard from you kind of like
what you've done what the impact has
been but let's shift the conversation to
talking about how you build the instant
app and how you design an instant
experience so let's start off with you
Olivia
what factors do you think make for a
great instant experience I think for us
it was really important you know you're
pretty much playing instantly and to
make sure that the player feels like
they're in pretty much experience right
away and it's really we've really picked
as you shown earlier really exciting
levels so we wanted to make sure we had
really great exciting and engaging
levels for the user experience so that
was for us really important that's why
we've selected certain levels as you can
see so certain levels have certain
boosters certain features to make sure
it's really different for every level
that they experience within the Google
Play instant experience yeah like you
rephrase the restate the question yet so
what factors make for a great instant
expiry yes
sorry don't missed it for a second there
so yeah certainly you know speed is
important so getting people immediately
into the core experience I think
probably goes without saying but I also
think it's important to redesign for the
use case
so at Zynga with optimization of
installs being sort of our primary
driver we're really trying to get an
experience that was concise and short so
that it ended in a clear opportunity to
expose a user to installing the full
experience I think if you were you know
doing something like a social invite or
using it for cross promotion or user
acquisition or different channels you
might have to think about the design for
that use case specifically so I think
use case is very important to understand
and exactly what KPI you're trying to
drive when building the experience this
is probably not necessarily one size
fits all fits all answer gotcha so well
for us what made sense was to assemble
before build like the first part of the
game
basically because we we know it's strong
so I wanted to share that and having the
possibility to then move to the full app
and and be able to carry over that
progress that that was the the use case
that ways but we see in the future
another possibilities of making probably
in another games that we do in some city
like just in different use cases and
optimize those for for each game so I
have a follow up for you so building a
game that meets the 10 megabyte size
limit sounds probably for many of you
like to be pretty intimidating but all
of you have successfully you know done
something like that and what my question
is for you is as you as you built out
the instant experience for for Panna pop
what are the kinds of things you learned
about you know both that process as well
as maybe things that you learned about
the the installed apps infrastructure
and so forth so our first idea was to
make the ascent 20 levels long being
able to go back and forth to them up and
then go to the game and then go to the
map again but again we realized that we
weren't going to achieve the size limit
goal that we had so at that point we get
together with the team and basically
decided to only do gameplay and do the
first 10 levels so that enabled us to
remove a lot of textures scenes that we
weren't using localization strings that
needs to be stripped off and
what we learn is that every little thing
that you can can remove from from the
app remove it because it's going to be
important
remove the plugins remove the local
essentials that children use even the
the smallest prefab it's important to
take it out so it's all cut out yeah
yeah so take away everything we try to
do it in a way where we could build it
on top of the regular game so we benefit
from changing from the changes that we
made in in the full app so I would also
recommend that if possible so you're
saying that it through that process you
were able to make optimizations that
then impacted your full game is that
right yes in fact there were two things
that we benefit from building the
instant up one was we improved the way
we were making bone animations and that
that made the application of run
smoother and with a reduced memory
footprint
so we basically in the full app we
gained memory and we gained performance
so it was truly beneficial it's awesome
and how what do you talk about what
about your experience he converted you
know and you know at least a couple of
games that I've had an opportunity to
play and what was your experience like
and how did you do that yeah so
fortunately in the case of single
solitaire the full app itself was just
around a 10 megabyte mark so we I didn't
have much difficulty getting in under
the threshold in that case in the case
of words with friends too
I think it was and this goes back to
sort of like the design piece of it as
well was really just having a clear
focus of what we wanted to bring to
consumers and so for us we launched
words of friends to about six months ago
one of the new features we launched with
that was a feature called solo series
which allows user
to play against AI powered BOTS we
thought that was a really good match for
the instant experience so he focused
exclusively on bringing a subset of solo
series to the instant app by having that
clear focus we were able to remove a lot
of other stuff that was tangential
unrelated and so we could really reduce
the app size and build a really clean
experience without a lot of the other I
won't call it fluff but aspects of the
app also so to synthesize that you're
saying that you know you can cut out
let's say lots of levels but the other
thing is to just focus on like one
particular slice of the experience yeah
exactly
that was a good summary be thoughtful of
you yeah so I think for us we just focus
a lot on the gameplay and then you know
we took out the saga map we don't have
any other features and a lot of our
games always have a narrative in the
beginning and if a2e so we obviously
took everything else it was only just
focused on the gameplay that's what we
wanted to focus on makes a lot of sense
and you know we've heard similar things
from a lot of our other partners as well
you know that's either stripping out
assets or choosing and select gameplay
but something's really good to get some
additional context from you up here so I
wanted to particularly talk to you about
some of the challenges related to
developing a instant experience in unity
and what are some of the things that you
you know ended up having to do and learn
through that process well as you mention
before the the biggest challenge for us
was size right sorry so we we needed a
summation before we needed to change the
way we were doing Dragonborn animations
because what we were using at the time
the device that was producing they were
bigger and they were also taking up a
lot of memory in the game and after that
we also needed to like refactor certain
point of certain parts of the code
to be able to only use the scene of the
gameplay I think those were the two
biggest challenges that we needed to
make but in the end we end up with a
more modular eyes application mm-hmm and
we were able to benefit from that in a
technical way also so it was a win-win
for us excellent and so looking forward
overall what kind of developments do you
see emerging in the instant gaming space
in the coming years yes you could go as
far in the future as you would like but
love to hear your thoughts on how you
see the whole space evolving I think
that this is going to be like probably
the I would say the future of user
acquisition also the social part of
being able to share a link and start
playing like right away that that's
probably going to be the future apps
that they're going to see and of course
we are going to benefit from them
awesome I think as you mentioned
especially with new games coming so
there's also a way you know to also
fully leverage their pre-registration on
Google Play right so players can
actually try the game before they
pre-register and actually install it so
I think that's another way and then you
know depending on where you are in you
know the stage for your game there could
be different instant games experiences
yeah I'm really excited to see what the
creativity of game developers will bring
to Google Instant and I think there will
be you know some breakout mechanic built
on top of Google instant Google Play
instance that to date would would not be
possible and so I think once you think
about it from a design perspective and
what you can bring it once there's no
friction between you know
a current user and a potential user or
reactivated user I think we'll be able
to build new mechanics on top of that
that are our breakout I wanted to give
you a big round of applause thank you
for being here and hope you all learned
a lot and I just wanted to close things
out with a collection of links so that
you can follow up and take action on the
things you learned today
so yes taking a photo was definitely
preferable because this last URL is
probably difficult to remember so Google
Play instant you know that's what you're
getting started guide is you can see the
technical documentation there there's a
beta sign up for for unity so if you
want to build a game with unity today we
encourage that obviously then you sign
up here to be part of our instant beta
and if you're interested and adventurous
and are willing to try something that's
hot off the press the alpha build of
Coco's creator with new features that we
described today you can go to this link
here and it's very stable I've been told
by the people from Coco's so go check it
out it's really cool we were demoing it
all week at @nc or whatever it is called
and it was stable be the way go check it
out I think you're gonna really get a
kick out of it and it's only gonna get
better from here
so thank you all for your time and enjoy
what remains of IO
[Music]